hallo ich bin's kai timo und ich begrüße
sie ganz herzlich zu diesem bild podcast
heute geht es um den herne killer
[Musik]
einer meiner hand und das ist das
einzige was stört
es ist april 2017 er nicht gerade
freundliche frühlingstag verabschiedet
sich aus dem kalender
es war den ganzen tag niedlich grau und
die bäume noch im halben winterschlaf
der stadtteil von herne genannt unser
fritz bekannt auch aus wanne eickel
liegt ruhig und beschaulich zwischen
einer schnellstraße und im fluss
es ist eine gartenstadt reihenhäuser mit
mittelklassewagen vor der einfahrt der
verbliebenen licht des tages wollten
einige jungs ihren fußball quer über die
straße gehen weil aufgeweckter
freundlicher und lieber junge ja kein
fußball gespielt es war ein zu viel
gewalt war sensibel sehr ehrlich und
fleißig und sehr hilfsbereit ein
unscheinbares reihenhaus doch
irgendetwas ist anders
plüschtiere und gedenkt karten stapeln
sich neben dem eingang blumen liegen
verwelkt neben trauer kerzen an der
einfahrt ein großes samt herz verliert
langsam durch die feuchtigkeit der
letzten wochen seine form überall steht
ein name im mittelpunkt in kinderschrift
in grafischen blätter mal ausgedruckt
mal selbst gemalt oder aufgenäht jaden
und herunter meister hin warum muss
hatte ich ihn dann direkt zur schule
und dann sagte er mir dass er das ist
nämlich so gut ginge schmerzen hat und
er öfter auf toilette musste aufgrund
dessen hatte ich den dann auch später
mittagessen frühen abends dann auch
nicht mitgenommen zum einkauf
jeanette es ist völlig erschöpft hinter
den müden augen erkennt man noch ab und
zu die fröhliche junggebliebene mutter
von drei kindern eine knallrot gefärbten
haarsträhne lugte unter der schwarzen
strickmütze hervor für das gespräch hat
sie etwas rouge aufgelegt um nicht allzu
blass aus zu sehen auch ihrem piercing
schmuck trägt sie heute kraftvoll stellt
sie sich gegen das gefühl einfach nur
noch zusammen brechen zu wollen sie ist
gerade von ihrem traurigen besuch auf
dem friedhof gleich hinter der nächsten
häuserzeile zurück ich gehe da überhaupt
nicht alleine hin wenn ist mein mann
dabei und auch da ist das nicht ganz so
einfach
man hat ja auch immer das bild hat die
augen dass er da unten im loch liegt
ganz alleine und das wo ich nicht
klarkommen
und dann bricht es doch aus ihr heraus
die kaffeetasse stellt sich schnell ab
atme tief ein es sind immer dieselben
fragen nach dem schrecklichen verbrechen
das sie vor einem monat wie eine
gewaltige dunkle welle unter sich
begruben wie ein kind nahm und diesen
kennt das leben ein ganzes leben wie
ging's jane was hat er gstadt sichtlich
gespürt hat da viel schmerzen gehabt war
der schnell bewusstlos dass er nicht so
viel mitgekriegt hat hat er angst gehabt
wollte dass seine mama bei ihm ist das
sind so sachen die wirklich immer extrem
in den abendstunden des 6 märz 2017 wird
ein neunjähriger junge aus herbe
ermordet und wenige stunden später am 17
märz ein 22-jähriger mann versprochen
aufgefunden beide verbrechen beging der
gleiche täter
polizei sprecherin nina vogt am abend
des 9 märz 2017 ich kann momentan sagen
dass wir hier in herne heute abend gegen
20 uhr 30
mann festgenommen haben der sich hier in
einem imbiss gemeldet hatte der dort die
polizei hat rufen lassen und uns
hinweise gegeben hat zu einer wohnung
hier ganz in der nähe in der wohnung hat
es gebrannt und wir haben dort zudem
eine männliche leiche gefunden
den man haben wir wie gesagt
festgenommen und mittlerweile können wir
auch bestätigen dass es sich dabei um
den gesuchten tatverdächtigen marcel
handelt der 19 jährige marcel h mörder
des neunjährigen jaden und des 22
jährigen christopher w wird ein jahr
später am 31 januar 2018 zu einer
lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
an dieser stelle könnte man die
berichterstattung beenden und angesichts
der morde an einem kind und einem jungen
mann einfach schweigen die taten des
marcel h beschäftigen aber noch heute
jahre nach der tat nicht nur die familie
von jaden deren leben nie wieder so sein
kann wie vorher
sondern auch ermittler therapeuten die
polizei und auch die familie des täters
das besondere an der tat in herne ist im
grunde genommen das durchtriebene das
eiskalte und geplante verhalten wirklich
keinerlei respekt vor dem leben zu haben
sondern nur einen ganz persönlichen
macht um tötungs rausch zu erleben
psychotherapeut christian lüdke versucht
heute jahre nach der tat so neutral wie
möglich zu wirken die sommer sonne
leuchtet seine praxis grell aus frische
blumen und wasser für die gäste stehen
auf dem tisch
er versucht aus den details der
ermittlungen aus den gesprächen von bild
mit der opfer und täter familie
polizisten und zeitzeugen ein
psychogramm des damals schnell lerne
killer genannten täters zu erstellen er
will die frage klären was für ein mensch
ist diese masse damals gewesen
noch zwei ältere geschwister kinderwagen
normal in der kunst polak männer
festgestellt dass er eine ads hatte
dafür hat mich dann verhalten natürlich
auf die mutter von most er seine
nachbarin von james familie war wenige
tage vor den morden mitten im umzug für
sie selbst mutter mehrerer kinder sind
die schmach und die qual täglich zu
wissen was ihr sohn angerichtet hat kaum
zu ertragen sie zeigt fotos von marcel
ein kleiner schmächtiger junge stroh
blond und schon zeitig mit einer starken
brille auf der nase bekam man eine
vierjährige behandlung beim psychologen
auf die realschule hatte er oft stress
mit wandern mit schülern auch schwedens
mutter hat muss er jeden tag gesehen und
sich schon früh besorgte gedanken
gemacht in der öffentlichkeit zeigte
dieser unscheinbare junge von nebenan
massive aggressivität gegenüber seiner
eigenen familie und freunden er war
schon sehr auffällig
war irgendwie wie ein geist der angina
augen geguckt wenn ich begegnet bin hat
er immer auf dem boden geguckt und es
waren da auch pikante situation gewesen
wo die schwester auch ihre freundin da
schützen musste weil sie angst hatte
dass er ihr irgendwas im körper eine
schwester hat sie so oft aufgeregt hat
auch ein blaues auge schon von ihm
geschlagen bekommen und dann kam sie mit
blauem auge und hat gesagt er hat ihre
mutter schon so oft gesagt der muss weg
gesperrt werden oder braucht
sichergestellt das ist nicht mehr normal
und erste gefahr für sich und andere
machen war damals ein cholerischer
sonderling hatte er sehr schwer
beziehungen aufzubauen auch für seine
eigene mutter wurde er immer mehr zum
rätsel am tag des verbrechens viel aber
auch michaela l auf dass irgendetwas
völlig ins rutschen gekommen war statt
in der küche näher sagt die mama ich war
zu meinen freund ahne ich werde auch da
übernachten ich habe das natürlich
geglaubt und da habe ich gemerkt habe
schaute mir nicht in die augen
aber ich habe das alles ganz normal
abgetan er packte seine sachen hat sich
dann von mir verabschiedet und stand auf
dem haus und sagt dann bis morgen dann
ist sowohl rübergegangen zu einer
nachbarin hat dann irgendwie die nach
der leiter gefragt
jedes mutter erinnert sich aus ihrer
sicht an die letzten minuten im leben
ihres sohnes sie klammert sich an fakten
und versucht ruhig zu bleiben dahinter
von dem darwin von den kleineren und
auch für den ganz großen gehört dass der
nachbar damir angeschaltete
gefragt hätte ob jay rüber kommen kann
die leiter festhalten jeanette s spürt
sofort dass etwas nicht stimmen kann und
geht zu den nachbarn bei denen licht
brennt und bei denen reden die leute
halten sollte da hatte ich angestellt
keine reaktion angeklopft können immer
hallo hallo berufen aber da hat sich
nichts gehört den kindern gesagt dass
der lette den jaden abgeholt drüben
brennt überall licht im ganzen haus ich
sage aber ich mache keine ob marcels
mutter michaela l war noch unterwegs und
bekam von jeanette f einen panischen die
nachbarin mich anrief bei dir im haus
brennt noch licht weil ich kann nicht
sein jedoch sagt sie da brennt licht und
dann wird man gar keine leiter holen nun
hab ich ein schreie gehört konnte dies
nicht resultieren richtig böse schreie
rosemarie gänsehaut gekriegt bin nach
oben gerannt genossen haus ausgeräumt
habe obwohl die schreie herkommt ist
mitgekriegt ich kommt von dem haus kann
man so schon in gegen der große und
warum schreien der schaden liegt im
keller auf dem boden alles ist voller
blut ich glaube das dauert
und dann ist aber auch zusammen
pascal f stiefvater von schäden fährt
sich im interview nervös durch die kurz
rasierten blonden haare setzt dann seine
schwarze baseballkappe wieder auf er
zieht hast dich an einer zigarette
während das tattoo an seiner
halsschlagader bebt und er irgendwie
versucht seine muskulösen oberarme unter
kontrolle zu halten mit einstichen die
man gesehen wie hoch gerutscht war und
dass diese genug mache mut und es werden
stücke teilen wir auf messen verteilt im
raum habe da noch mal versucht es
irgendwie zu tun was
versucht was man irgendwie tun könnte
was
man eigentlich erst moment schon gesehen
was aus deinem sinn hat die polizei
kommt am 6 märz gegen 20 uhr 30 in das
haus des 19 jährigen marcel hesse in der
breite straße im ortsteil unser fritz in
herne an zu diesem zeitpunkt ist der
stiefvater des verschwundenen jeden mit
einem seiner beiden anderen söhne durch
die offen stehende terrassentür in das
haus gelangt und findet den jungen im
keller vor das 9 jährige opfer weist
eine vielzahl von messerstichen auf die
wiederbelebungsversuche des stiefvaters
bleiben erfolglos
beamten die als erstes eingetroffen sind
habe ich kurz mit dem keller begleitet
haben nicht umgedreht sind wieder hoch
die rettungssanitäter sind inklusive dem
notarzt im keller ein rettungssanitäter
kamen umgehend wieder raus das ist auch
eine form haus eingesetzt und
er bekommt
nun hört auch nachbarin michael am
telefon dass offenbar etwas
schreckliches in ihrem ehemaligen haus
passiert ist und fährt sie rad halten
adresse gehört dort völlig unerwartet
das erste mal von dem verdacht dass ihr
sohn marcel ein kindermörder ist
imstande hahn krankenwagen gesehen
mehrere polizeiautos die nachbarin
geliebter schreiend umher und schrie
immer mein sohn ist tot mein sohn ist
tot und ich stand da wie ochs vorm berg
wusste nicht was los war man ließ mich
da nicht rein und ich stand da immer
noch perplex tod kann auch nicht sein
weil es passiert und dann sagt er einen
kripo-beamte neben mir ja ihr sohn muss
wohl den gegner umgebracht haben mit
mehreren messerstichen
die polizei beginnt sofort mit den
ermittlungen schnell finden sie die
sprachnachrichten von marcel h in denen
er sich seiner tat rühmt auf der
berüchtigten foren plattform von shell
die immer wieder durch rechtsextreme
frauenfeindliche rassistische und gewalt
verherrlichen will gruppen chats aufhält
der 56 jährige polizeihauptkommissar
volker schütte aus bochum ist sachlich
den wut darf heute wie damals
ermittlungen nicht behindern das bild
oder das foto von meister hätte glaube
ich kannte fast jeder deutsche
bundesbürger wir hatten es mit einem
serienmörder zu tun was aber besonders
war an dieser sache erst mit seinen
taten gerühmt sie ins internet
eingestellt hat sie kommentiert
gar nicht so besonders sein einer meiner
hand bietet jetzt das einzige was stört
auch andreas jäschke leiter der
mordkommission chat war sich sicher dass
der mörder sich wieder im internet
äußern würde und dass die ermittler so
neue spuren zur weit und fahndung
bekommen könnten
hinzu kam dass reporter schnell wind von
dem grausigen verbrechen bekamen bild
titelte schon am nächsten tag 19
jähriger tötet neunjährigen in
tarnkleidung auf der flucht man könnte
jetzt nicht mehr nicht mehr sich
fokussieren auf die reine fahnung
sondern man muss auch gucken was wir wo
kommuniziert und das unter dem zeitdruck
dass der täter nochmal drei tagen
angekündigt vielleicht wirklich noch ein
nachbar über macht auch gleich
physiotherapeut christian lüdke erinnert
sich an ähnliche fälle in seiner praxis
arbeitet ein täter sagte mal im normalen
leben da bin ich ein niemand und im
internet bin ich ein jemand also es ist
nicht nur eine trophäe mit dem er seinen
machtrausch verlängern sondern es ist
für ihn die möglichkeit für ein paar
augenblicke die aufmerksamkeit anderer
user zu genießen marcel war diese
aufmerksamkeit so wichtig dass er
weitere morde plante er fühlte sich
stark und genoss es möglicherweise sogar
dass die polizei nach ihm suchte und er
plötzlich so ein wichtiger staatsfeind
war nach hause konnte er nicht also ging
er zu einem kumpel mit dem er schon
öfters computer gespielt hatte
polizeihauptkommissar schütte berichtet
herd an einen alten bekannten aufgesucht
wirklich nur einen bekannten der hat ihm
unterschlupf gewährt allerdings ist ja
unter einer legende in diese wohnung
gekommen der später verstorbene
christopher wusste nichts von der vortat
die beiden jungen männer haben zusammen
zunächst gegessen man hat
im internet gespielt letztlich hat man
nicht um 2 uhr schlafen gelegt so das
war der zeitpunkt wo wir dabei waren die
erste pressemeldung zu fertigen
christopher warnte nicht welchen
psychopathen er sich da ins haus geholt
hatte als er seinen fehler bemerkte war
es bereits zu spät dann ist irgendwann
der christopher morgens wach geworden
hat wikinger wahrscheinlich ins internet
geschaut und hat ja dann ja ich sag mal
seinen bekannten der direkt neben auf
dem sofa lag als mörder im facebook
gesehen erding darauf angesprochen ja
und man muss sagen dass wo das
todesurteil für christopher denn dann
ist der unmittelbar danach von marcel
hesse mit 68 messerstichen bestialisch
getötet worden da hab ich jetzt zwei
monaten hat
der chef der mordkommission streicht
sich durch den grauen fast weißem bart
und denkt zurück wir die
menschenverachtenden postings von marcel
wieder und wieder hörte wir haben ja
auch definitiv posting von ihm erhalten
in dem er dann weitere taten angekündigt
hat bzw davon gesprochen
in die richtung verlagert also wie meine
frau handelt das ist die führung in dem
fall von täter auch gestört wurde die
polizei war musste schon auf der spur
aber der hatte zugang zum internet und
war bestens darüber informiert wie die
fahndung lief ein problem für die
ermittler wie der bochumer polizei
hauptkommissar im nachhinein fest stellt
leider war zu diesem zeitpunkt marcel
hesse schon in der wohnung an der
sedanstraße er hatte die möglichkeit
dort ins internet zu schauen über den
internetzugang von christopher wird
genau gewusst haben wgc die einzelnen
aktionen
gelaufen sind er wird möglicherweise
unsere pressemeldung gelesen haben mit
sicherheit aber die berichterstattung in
den medien für deutschland war der
mörder war schnell klar dass fliehen
nichts mehr bringen würde und er wollte
ja auch irgendwie gefasst werden was
dann nach knapp drei tagen auch geschah
am abend des 9 märz 2017 stellte sich
marcel h in einem griechischen
schnellimbiss an der bismarckstraße in
herne der polizei
seine linke hand war verletzt er wies
bei seiner festnahme darauf hin dass in
der nähe in der sedanstraße eine wohnung
brenne die feuerwehr löschte den brand
und fand dort die zweite leiche
marcela gestand er bestritt die tat
gegenüber der polizei die nachricht auf
eine zweite möglicherweise getötete
person hatte sich offenkundig auf den
bekannten bezogen bei dem er kurz nach
der tat unter schock gefunden hatte am
folgenden tag tötete er den bekannten
nachdem dieser angekündigt hatte die
polizei einzuschalten
[Musik]
nachdem der täter gefasst war ging es
schnell um das verzweifelte warum diese
schreckens tragen was trieb marcel h so
brutal aus der gesellschaft auszubrechen
selbst der leiter der damaligen
mordkommission ist fassungslos über das
ausmaß der gewalt gegen wehrlose opfer
der geschichte ist dass viele die
massivität der
einstellung bei daraufhin einfach 52
messerstichen
68 messerstichen der täter hat hier also
massiv gemalt psychotherapeut lüttge
knetet seine hände als müsste er aus den
taten des mörders einen sinn
herauspressen ging es dem täter nicht
nur um das töten er hätte dann auch
einstieg möglicherweise gereicht sondern
das klassische über töten und das ist
die markenzeichen der psychologie des
täters das heißt es geht hier darum
macht zu genießen nur einen blutrausch
zu genießen herr über leben und tod zu
sein aber es scheint noch einen feed
banaleren zusätzlichen grund wie die
taten zu geben
als auslöser der tat gilt unter anderem
eine absage der bundeswehr auf eine
bewerbung von marcel h
polizeihauptkommissar volker schütte
erklärt die einschneidenden ereignisse
im leben des täters die offenbar zur
gewalteskalation führten werde die
schule abgebrochen hätte sich wohl weil
der bundeswehr geworben hatte einen
abschlägigen bescheid bekommt hat er
dann die absage bekam brachte ihn
natürlich nur wells zusammen das hat man
ihn auch angemerkt er hatte sogar so
fest damit gerechnet dass ich seine
langen haare dann schon abrasiert hatte
obwohl ich ihm sagte er solle es doch
sein lasst uns mal abwarten ob man ihm
abnehmen würde ich will dich arbeiten
deswegen müssen sich der einzige grund
ich musste bewerbungsschreiben
[Musik]
masse gibt seine lustlosigkeit und
verachtung für die gesellschaft also
selbst in einem weiteren posting preis
die mordkommission chat durchforstet
weiterhin marcels timeline und kommt zu
einer erschreckenden einschätzung wenn
ich hatte in der vernehmung ohne
umschweife beide taten eingeräumt habt
ihr auch relativ detailliert und ja man
kann sagen kühl geschildert die
produktions los geschildert und
hat im rahmen dieser beschreibung auch
geschildert was deine beweggründe
waren um den beiden karten zu begehen da
sah er sich halt irgendwo auf der straße
deswegen hat er sich gedanken dazu
gemacht wie kann ich diesen umstand für
mich persönlich verändern deshalb hat er
dann entschieden etwas tun zu müssen wo
er auf längere sicht ins gefängnis
kommen würde kann das morden so banal
sein
psychotherapeut lücke
die täter haben ein vollständig anderes
unrechtsbewusstsein sie sehen sich als
opfer die er selber keine liebe keine
zuwendung erfahren haben ist das jetzt
kriege ich nicht ich meine ich könnte
mich als aufhänger war es gab also
halbherzige selbstmordversuche der als
postings angekündigt hatte
laut polizei bochum hatte es diese
versuche auch tatsächlich gegeben die
man von marcels mutter erfuhr
kohle die akn katzenstreu rein getan und
hat versucht sich damit zu vergessen er
hat versucht sich zu strangulieren er
hat versucht einen grill in dem haus
anzuzünden das ist nicht gelungen obwohl
er die wohnung abgelichtet hat dann hat
er relativ schnell den entschluss
gefasst eine person zu töten irgendeine
selbstmordversuche und dann wird
erklärt das so
relativ hohen planungs grad gehabt und
das andeuten und ankündigen eines
selbstmordes kann möglicherweise jeder
versuch gewesen sein das ganze zu
verschleiern zu verharmlosen oder
möglicherweise dann auch für sich
persönlich an schuld ausschließungsgrund
im vorhinein schon mal fest so schnell
es ist also möglich das ist der plan war
nach den morden als opfer dazu stehen
schuldunfähig zu sein und so mit
besseren haftbedingungen davonzukommen
mord kommissionsleiter jaschke sieht das
ganz klar als vorsatz er wollte schon
jemanden töten aber der schaden war halt
ein zufallsopfer der ist ein angreifer
gewesen hätte es wahrscheinlich mit
diesem jungen ein bekenntnis dass die
leiter zu keiner zeit gefahren also das
war schon recht emotions unserem kühl
und wie ein diktat
heruntergebetet von daher hat er sich da
hat er zu keinem zeitpunkt gefahr
psychotherapeut lüdtke nimmt einen
schluck wasser und äußert seine
abschließende sicht auf den 19 jährigen
mörder meiner einschätzung nach handelt
es sich bei dem täter um einen
antisozialen täter früher hat man die
alles so zu parken oder psychopathen
bezeichnet
quasi sowie im schweigen der lämmer hahn
überlegter die kunstfigur das sind täter
die eiskalt sind sie sind durch trieben
sie sind berechnen sie haben keine
gefühle sie kennen keine gefühle sie
können nur reaktionen auf gefühle und
das spiegelt sich zum teil auch in dem
brief wieder den der täter an seine
mutter geschrieben hatte eine sehr
persönliche herzlose anrede alles ist
ganz sachlich ganz nüchtern geschrieben
kein gefühl schon bedauern von reue von
trauer gar nichts das ist ein indiz dann
ist die sorge um das haustier größer als
die sorge um den menschen das kennt man
bei vielen antisoziale
persönlichkeitsstörungen dass solche
täter immer noch reste von bindung zu
tieren haben als ich jemals zu einem
menschen an
der brief des mörders uns erreichte
marcels mutter michaela kurz nach der
verhaftung während eines gesprächs mit
den bild reportern kater schröder löste
dabei auf der kirchenbank sie öffnet den
brief sofort und ließ die eigenartigen
zahlen
[Musik]
ich schätze aus dem zen-kloster wird
wohl nichts spaß beiseite wie geht es
dem schröder ich fürchte er wird nicht
mehr erleben wenn ich hier raus bin aber
pflege wenigstens die lilly ok meine
schwester hat mir gesagt du bist froh
dass ich weg bin zum einen hoffe ich
dass die seine defensive aussage ist um
nicht als die mutter des satans zu
gelten zum anderen würde ich es dir
nicht übel nehmen in jedem fall ich
hoffe du hast nichts dagegen wenn zellen
die mein eigentum an sich nimmt
hauptsächlich da sie interesse hat und
das schade finde wenn ihr sie einfach
entsorgt solltest du keinen weiteren
kontakt mehr pflegen wollen gibt
wenigstens deiner tochter bescheid damit
beide du und ich abschließen können
machte endlich mal auf deine ernährung
sonst glaube ich wird der schröder sich
überlegen ich weiß nicht wie ich damit
umgehen soll keine ahnung wieso
gut hass ich habe alles eher mehr an
gefühlen die man zu haben und ich weiß
wie das sein muss als mutter
wenn man seine kinder verliert
dann schweigt michael sie kann nicht
mehr sprechen beladen mit einer schuld
die nicht die ihre ist wird sie nun
weiter leben müssen
jaden smith jeannette f hat für sich und
ihren mann pascal kaffee gemacht
aber kein koffein der welt hilft gegen
diese unendliche müdigkeit und
verschlagenheit im kopf es bleibt nur
die blanke verzweiflung bei uns in einer
trauergruppe heißt er es für mich
menschlich da hat sich einer hilflosen
kind verlangt wenn ich keinen kein
mensch mehr man kann nicht nicht nicht
nur ansatzweise sich vorstellen
was fast jemand platz um zu berichten
in einem kleinen kind überlassen was
kann man nicht nachvollziehen ich glaube
ich nie verstehen was da so hinter nun
sind wir so
was dran ich finde einfach nur was gut
und
absolut nix
in der nächsten ausgabe geht es um den
schneekönig ronald million er gilt auch
als deutscher pablo escobar seine fast
schlafwandlerisch cooles brachte ihn
viele jahre ins gefängnis wenn dir
dieser podcast gefällt bewerte ihn gerne
da wo du ihn hörst
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild produziert von den world studios
projektleitung lutz neumann und simone
terbrack produktion fabian schaeffler
und felix stehenbleiben bildredaktion
christina schneider und stefan netzeband
sprecher skyteam